jacqueline let me hear you out though so
so for
do you have another scene that kind of
typifies why this movie will
will trick you even you jacqueline coley
who knows you're being tripped
yeah and that's what it's getting to
it's like it's the manipulation into the
separate of it because the middle part
is the part that you have to forget
and the scene that sort of solidifies
that for me is the scene that even gets
them back together
because in my personal idea is if this
was an actual story
they never see each other again
basically ally
is doing what you know you do when
you're unhappy with your life checking
your ex's instagram
when she picks up that newspaper and
sees that he has built that house
that scene says way more than you can
realize it's him like
talking about how we built the house
they take the picture flash forward to
ally she's trying on her wedding dress
after james marsden has proposed they
are both moving into a different place
he was building the house in a form of
manipulation
he was essentially building the house to
say look i'm gonna do something
with myself despite the fact that
obviously she didn't think that i could
that's the reason why he says as soon as
he built it he was thinking about
burning it to the ground
because it wasn't really about achieving
something it was really about showing
her up
and then it worked because then she sees
it
and all of a sudden she can't be
satisfied with her life because she sees
oh he's got this pretty house now and i
know what that means and all these other
things
the entire moment that led them to
reconnect
was a form of manipulation and so it
doesn't matter what happens after that
it feels toxic and i know it was maybe
based on a deep
personal and passionate love but it
doesn't make any sense
these two people don't get to be
grandparents that was my whole point
you have to make them grandparents is
the only way to believe it because if
you end the story with just ali and noah
we know how this ends they're not
together in six months is it fail too
much
are you kidding you look perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
you better let me see oh boy
it's a fair point mod is that if they
didn't bookend it the way that they did
in this movie i don't know that
i'm buying into the just the specifics
of the the young relationship
you know like because where's poor jimmy
marsden's chance to
why can't did he even know that um
oh he built you a house okay let me see
if i can build your house let me see if
i can buy you a bigger house that's
wider that has more blue shutters
the house is a symbol it's not the fact
that it's a materialistic house
it's the symbol of him wanting to have
their lives together
does it show that when they split up she
was kind of able to move on
and was happy and had a great guy yes
was he able to move on
never did he remain obsessed with her
and couldn't ever
move past absolutely is that dangerous
you bet but the house was a symbol the
whole thing was symbolism
of i know you i know what you want
and i'm gonna do what i can to give that
to you um
i think that it was there was like icky
moments in there where he was seeing
sort of like the the widow and she
really liked him
and he had that wall up and she was
trying to break it down and that
couldn't happen
oh that the existence of the house
but the fact that you know everything
that she said just on a whim i want a
white house i want the blue shutters i
want a wrap around veranda so i can see
the water and i want to be able to
change
so i can see hey that's a great
checklist
don't kill someone for having a dream
she's much she's building the barbie
dream house and then this poor guy while
she's off having a flint and extended
fling that involves
financial stability and a good life
promised
he is now just tasked day after day with
building this
thing for her the malibu dream house and
he has no idea
he needed a purpose and that was his
hobby that's what he did to kind of like
either find sanity or just remain in his
craze but that's
that's the thing that he decided to do
never knowing if it was ever going to
see fruition
yeah i think most therapists would tell
you that having a hobby in an outlet is
great to help you get over
a failed relationship but maybe don't
pick the hobby that's going to make you
think about her even more
every day for the rest of your life
until
you see her because let's face it he's
building that house he looks like
kobe in the finals i mean he has his
game face on
he's growing out his amityville horror
[Music]
beard
[Music]
you